[Music]
hey there I'm Ken I'm also Ken and i'm
cornrow ken I'm mad bun Ken it's kind of
my thing
I guess I'm emo Ken so mainstream I
always think about ken is the guy you
trust
you know he's not gonna Punk you or
anything he's just a he's a nice guy the
nice guy he is a fashion horse he's
really quite playful of but that I kind
of pictured in kind of Ryan Seacrest II
in my in my opinion the beauty of Cadiz
is anybody water would be he's the guy
the gym right really the guy next door
you can trust in the lesbian the perfect
boyfriend we may all be named Ken but we
couldn't be more different
that's true there are hundreds of
different Ken's one for each of our
favorite person party this is where
we're from Mattel headquarters in sunny
SoCal these are parents they decide what
we wear style our hair and give us the
fiercest there and now Ken's don't just
have different jobs and hobbies we have
different bodies - I'm original Ken I'm
skinnier and slightly shorter can and
I'm wait what do I called again and
here's a more kind of husky version cuz
he is abroad can rocket yeah broad oh
okay I was call him husky okay okay
husky Ken was definitely rejected rod
felt the most appropriate most positive
well broad can you know the toy world
and play is about bigger than life so I
think when things
look kind of bigger than life okay like
the entire Barbie brand will continue to
evolve every single can in store and
online is cat the only differentiator is
their fashion the rapid and rocking can
the Harley Davis you can sweet-talking
10 was a really fun 10 Toy Story Ken had
a really huge moment
so great family love this kind of long
baggy shorts shaking fun Ken I mean this
is like because what it had this really
great magical transforming future right
[Music]
having different Ken's has never been
more important than it is now
whether it's 60s can or skinny black
hipster ken ken Affleck or Henry Cavill
or midlife crisis Ken there's ken for
everybody
GQ is the best magazine ever